Preparing for more war.
That is what NATO's says
Putin is doing tonight.
But but while Putin makes slight
gains in eastern Ukraine,
his military is still suffering
heavy losses
You can see
we're going to show you in this new video
into OUTFRONT.
This is a night vision
recording of an attack
by Ukraine on Russian troops
in eastern Ukraine.
According to Ukrainian forces,
the Russian convoy
unexpectedly move in, moved
in on the Ukrainian forces.
And Ukraine responded.
I'm going to show you the aftermath
from the air.
Complete destruction.
The turret of a combat vehicle
just torn off.
And then we'll show you from the ground.
Russian fighting
vehicles blown to pieces. Really?
This is only one part of the problem
facing Putin's forces tonight.
A growing divide
also between Putin's official army
and his private volunteer force
is also impacting the fight.
Today,
the volunteer chief is accusing
Russia's defense ministry
of, quote, treason.
All by
the chief of the general staff
and the minister of defense
are handing out commands right and left
that the Wagner PMC
should not receive ammunition
They're also not helping
with air transport.
What is your advice?
There is direct opposition.
This can be equated to high treason.
All of this as Putin and Biden
both delivered major addresses
today in advance of the one year
anniversary of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine.
Biden declaring in no uncertain terms
the commitment of the US
and NATO to help Ukraine
while Putin rattles his nuclear saber.
Biden spoke in Poland just hours
after his historic visit to Kiev.
One year ago,
the world was bracing
for the fall of Kiev.
Well, I've just come from a visit to Kiev
and I can report kif stand strong
Key stands proud.
It stands tall,
and most important, it stands free.
President Putin is craving lust for land
and power will fail
and the Ukrainian people's love
for their country will prevail.
Democracies of the world
will stand guard.
Our freedom today tomorrow and forever.
But Putin isn't going to be giving up
anytime soon.
Tonight, he's
getting support from one of his biggest
and most powerful allies China.
China's top
diplomat arriving in Moscow today
for meetings.
And according to The Wall Street
Journal, Chinese
President Xi Jinping
is now planning to meet
with Putin in Moscow.
In the coming months.
We've got
all the angles covered for you tonight.
Let's start with Phil Mattingly.
He's in Warsaw.
That's where Biden spoke today,
of course.
Phil, how closely was
Biden watching Putin
you know, when you talk to U.S.
officials, they made clear
this speech was not a focal point
of the president's day
in order to drive
major edits or changes to the address.
He gave just a few hours later in Warsaw.
Their view of President Biden's
goal with the remarks
today, remarks
that he'd been planning and
telling advisers
he wanted to make for several months
was to make a larger argument,
paint a broader picture of the war
that's ongoing
and the kind of stakes at hand
for Western democracies, not just Russia.
Not just Ukraine.
However, the president was explicit
in his rebuke
of President
Putin, mentioning his name
ten separate times,
attempting to put to rest
the very argument
President Putin made for why
Russia invaded.
In his remarks today,
but also over the course of the last
11 months,
that was intentional
and something
White House officials made clear.
The president wanted to do
in an explicit manner.
But the broader goal of the speech,
laying out the
stakes, laying out the dynamics
here, underscored
something that was very clear. And U.S.
officials have seen in those hour
and 45 minute remarks
from President Putin today,
and that is that there is no endgame
anytime soon. There is no off grant ramp.
There is no indication whatsoever
that President Putin
is going to decelerate
an effort
that has only been expanding
over the course of the last 11 months,
and that, more
than anything else, has driven
the president's actions
the last several days,
trying to underscore
that for all of the progress,
all of the ability to defend Ukraine
and keep the coalition together
over the course,
the 11 months, last
11 months,
there is a long and difficult path ahead.
And this fight is about more
than just Ukraine and Russia,
something
the president wanted to get across.
Now, it's worth
noting our colleagues Oren
Liebermann and Natasha
Bertrand are reporting
that Russia actually
engaged in a intercontinental ballistic
missile test yesterday
while President Biden was in Kiev.
According to sources, that test U.S.
officials believe failed.
It was not considered an anomaly,
nor was it
considered an escalation, something
the Russians tested before in the past.
But it was expected
to have been mentioned
in President Putin's remarks
earlier today. Had it been successful?
You'll notice
it was absent from those remarks.
They believe it failed Kate.
So interesting.
Good to see you. Phil, thank you so much.
And well, as Phil
mentioned, Biden mentioned
Putin by name
ten times in his speech today.
Putin
Putin did not mention Biden
once in his lengthy address in Moscow.
Matthew Chance is OUTFRONT
with a
fanfare the Russian president
takes to the stage
for a long awaited State
of the nation address.
But nearly a year
since his invasion of Ukraine,
no sign of remorse or regret.
Only bitterness towards the West.
Activists in the region
The responsibility
for fueling the Ukrainian conflict,
for its escalation,
for the number of victims
lies completely
with Western elites
and of course,
with the current Kiev regime
for whom the Ukrainian people
are essentially strangers.
By blaming others inside,
the Kremlin tries
to explain why
its special military operation.
Let's move down this way
to last just days or weeks,
almost in its second year
with no end in sight.
We've learned that what we thought
we might
across Russia,
there were even
public screenings of the speech
to ensure the Kremlin message is heard
that military setbacks, failures
and bloodshed
are all part of a conspiracy
to bring Russia to its knees.
It is up to me
where words very easily
the Western elites
do not conceal their goals,
as they say, it's a direct quote
to bring Russia a strategic defeat.
What does that mean for us?
It means to end us once and for all.
We understand it exactly,
and we'll react to it accordingly,
because this is about the very
existence of our country.
It doesn't feel that way in Ukraine,
where troops are dying on
bleak battlefields,
defending grim front lines
against a Russian foe.
Ukrainian officials pouring
scorn on Putin's remarks as irrelevant
and confused
There's growing criticism in Russia
to his new images
emerge of more coffins
reportedly from the front lines.
One prominent Russian
military blogger
complained that Putin held back
from officially declaring war,
not a word about failures and defeats,
he writes.
There's no point listening any further,
but I see.
But there was one major new announcement,
one escalation
to applause
Putin suspending participation
in Moscow's last remaining
nuclear arms treaty
with the United States.
And a warning that Russia may restart
nuclear tests
between you and me and say,
what do we do?
Of course we will not do it first.
But if the U.S.
conducts its tests,
we will do it as well.
Nobody should have dangerous illusions
that global strategic
parity can be broken.
No illusion either.
When it
comes to Russia's standoff with the West,
the Kremlin is even thinking
about backing down
After hearing
Putin's uncompromising speech.
A source close to the Ukrainian
president told me tonight
that the only way
this ever going to be peace
talks is if there are more Ukrainians
victories on the battlefield.
The sooner Ukraine gets the weapons
it needs, this source told me.
The sooner this war can come to an end.